what is the appeal of cattle and and
black cat for you well nothing on the
Chester at all no and she i love
Catwoman she's such a feisty character
and well she gets on with Batman quite a
bit so that's alright black
well Vicki wanted to do a pair cosplay
and I love spider-man so tell me about
these costumes because you're looking
mighty fine I'm gonna say both of you
where'd you get this from and well most
of it from eBay actually but I put it
together myself so it's quite hard to
get everything all together in one place
but you what kind of look inspired to
you because Catwoman has come in many
guises has a chain and well I'm actually
the Adam Hughes version he's done comic
covers for Catwoman and he does the
specific red goggles and I love the red
goggles so I decided to go is that
kemppi are you in that or is it super
hearts oh it's going hot yeah I'm not at
all comfy and you definitely can't stand
around for very long in these heels how
about you black cats most of my costumes
is like assembled like world of internet
with like bits of fur sewn on but I made
the mask how do cover cats keep cool
during a convention like this
trying to stay near draw severe open
doors that helps and drinking a lot and
what about cosplay tips so the people
who might be just starting out and be
confident in what you do and never do
something half-assed always go for all
the way and how about you but I can I
think pretty much the same thing if you
put your heart into it people can tell
it doesn't matter if the character
doesn't look like you just as long as
you put your heart into it
you